we're going to do a little bit of
opening preparation today we're going to
understand a little bit why some of the
openings that exist exist and how they
came up with it and a little bit on the
chronological order of how chess was
thought of so we're going to start a
little bit basic we're going to start
with some basic chess ideas so for
example development does everybody know
development is anybody want to venture
their definition of development yeah
very good so basically the idea of
development that you're bringing out
your pieces two really good squares now
let's define really good squares where
are you usually try to fight near the
beginning yeah for the center right so
we're going to be focusing mainly on the
center whoever controls the center at
the beginning of the game has a really
good chance of initiating either an
attack or a counter-attack depending on
what their opponent's doing because they
have a greater control of the board
whoever controls the center is in a
really good spot in the game so
therefore we easily get some of the main
moves that exist for white now in chess
70% of the games are more or less played
with the moves
efore and d4 so both efore and d4 are
very common but there are other moves
that also challenge the center may mean
a little bit of a different way so we'll
go through them a little bit later but
just to tell you that there Knight of 3
and C for other moves though they exist
are not as common
the idea behind chess I call a game
called shot rang was played in India
thousands of years ago but it's not the
chest that we know nowadays there they
had slightly different rules yeah
in the medieval times all right getting
a little closer alright just as we know
it now is thought to be fully developed
in the Renaissance so close enough but
the first historical records we have of
games date back to the 1600s of actual
chess games now we do have some other
variations on the game but actual chess
are in the 1600s and they already came
up with very interesting ideas such as
the center it was actually one of the
first ideas that was ever seen in chess
so efore was played all the way back in
the 1600s and most everybody replied
with the more logical move which is e 5
so back then everybody play like this
none not yet the Spanish right so here
let's continue fighting for the center s
white yeah so Knight f3 is very logical
it puts pressure on e5 and black has to
defend against the threat right so what
are possible moves here mm-hmm
these six is called the Philidor defense
now does anybody know who fielder was
anybody filter filter was one of the
first people to write about chess so he
actually published the chess book and
this was back in the 1700s so this was
actually a little bit later than the
first games of chess first games of
chess actually thought hey this guy's
attacking my pawn with the knight I'll
defend it with a knight so how do you
think they want yeah sure
knight c6 which is the more common idea
now what has to keep putting pressure in
the center he can do this in many
different ways there are three moves
that are more popular than the others
anybody care to guess which ones they
are mm-hmm yeah
Bishop c4 was the first move that was
ever really tried Bishop c4 is very
natural it puts the bishop in a good
square it cannot really be attacked
it controls d5 it puts pressure on f7
which is a little bit weak and it's
overall a good developing move right it
allows me to castle on the next move
excellent Bishop c4 is what we're going
to see first what other moves are there
yeah Bishop where b5 right Bishop b5 so
this is called the real Lopez and that's
called real Opus because of real Oh PES
that's actually a monk name in Spain in
the 1600s that also wrote about chess
and he came up with this idea of Bishop
b5 now the idea of it should be 5 is
that it fights for the center in a
slightly different way it's called an
indirect way the bishop targets the
knight on c6 which is the only defender
of the center that white the black house
right now so this has been an idea for
many many years and the last idea is a
little bit more modern it's called the
scotch game and it goes d4 all right
let's focus on Bishop c4 first so after
Bishop c4 what would be a natural way of
playing yeah
Knight f6 is very normal yeah this one
so you're saying that you cannot play
negative 6 because 9 g5 I will be put
threatening f7 now that's a line this is
actually possible for black and for
white this has been played at the
Grandmaster level many many times
actually this was played a few years ago
at this club if I remember correctly
between I want to say Hikaru Nakamura
and Josh Fidel two of the top
grandmasters in America so it's possible
to play this for both sides 96 is not a
mistake what else what's a more natural
developing move yeah they should Bishop
c5 correct
now many moves here have been tried for
black for white but early on in chess
people understood the power of
development so in in many cases oops
in many cases where did it go back to
their ego so in many cases here white
started to think how to sacrifice
material to be able to bring his pieces
out as quickly as possible so what would
be a natural move here just a normal
move here yeah castling is very normal
right and that leads to what's called
the Italian game it's a very slow very
steady very stable game but people
decided hey I want to fight for the
center immediately I want to put all my
pieces in good squares yeah they could
play Knight c3 which is also a good
developing move yeah
they could play d3 which leads to a very
similar position as castling usually
they play that either d3 first or
castling first and then the other the
other move or they can play c3 now c3 so
a little bit of a mysterious move which
rule is it violating yeah
right it's blocking me in this night
right so what's the deal why is he
blocking in the night yeah so he wants
to play d4 so here we have this idea of
the center coming back and back and back
again so here of course the point is
that I'm reinforcing the square and I
can push my pawn forward two squares to
d4 and then black would have to deal
with my strong pawn center so black has
to find a way to prevent this he can't
do that directly but he can try to
continue his development so black played
what's a normal developing move here
anybody else just develop yeah 9sx
correct
so after Knight of six what was White's
ID and here we're going to follow a game
between greco and an unknown player
unfortunately history has lost who was
the opponent of Greco in this game so
what was White's idea yeah d4 correct
so after d4 I'm attacking the bishop
right black has no time to take the pawn
on e4 which is currently undefended so
it's true that this bond doesn't have
any protection but it doesn't matter
because I'm attacking the bishop right
now black took on d4 and why to Conde
for right now can black capture capture
this again why not yeah
so ha but what's the detail here yeah
and the Queen takes bishop right and who
ends up ahead in this exchange yeah how
much a bishop for a for a pawn correct
right if we count what has two three
four five six pawns Black has seven but
he's missing a piece right I have an
extra Bishop so this is no good for
white and this is no good for black
sorry so he needs to move the bishop
away and he would rather do it with a
temple or winning time what do you think
he played yeah ah ha he can move it
several squares but this one is the best
because it forces White's reaction so
now white has to defend against this
check and he can do it in one of several
ways yeah yeah so Bishop d2 is possible
that's one move what's another yeah
Knight c3 so now here Greco is offering
a pawn who is defending the pawn on e4
mm-hmm
then I don't see three is defending the
pawn on e4 right but what's wrong with
this logic yeah back there
so this night is actually not supporting
this pawn because this bishop is hitting
the king right now we call this a pin
what type of pin is this yeah yeah you
it's an absolute pin right once the
bishop is on before that nine is on c3
the knight cannot legally move because
there's a king behind it and the pin is
absolute so can black take on e4 and he
did however Greco had an idea in mind he
doesn't mind giving away his material as
long as he can develop quickly and open
lines against his King so what do you
think he played here there are many
ideas you can keep developing these
sorry idea what okay castle yeah any
other ideas or are we do we all agree or
castling yes
Bishop d2 is also possible defending the
knight right but back when just started
back in the 1600s everybody was very set
on this idea of destroying your opponent
King the idea of strategy the idea of
long term advantages that ideas of pawn
structures that we have nowadays did not
quite exist back then so instead people
focused on giving away their material
and trying to really kill their opponent
as quickly as possible with the few
pieces that he had available and this is
what they did back then
so Greco castled trying to bring in the
rook into the game nowadays we know that
this approach doesn't really work if
black knows what they're doing it is
possible to counter white very
aggressive approach by having a little
bit more of a balanced
response however balance wasn't really
known back in the in the day what was
known was greed and the idea of taking
as much
material as possible and hoping that you
didn't get checkmated which worked
sometimes it didn't work the others so
in this position black decided to take
on c3 with the night trying to capture
another pawn so Knight takes c3 B takes
c3 Bishop takes c3 now it's hitting the
rook right so here was breakfast
opponents idea he wants to hit the rook
and he wants to castle on the next move
because let's say that I move my rope
there seems to be the only way to defend
it right and then I have enough time to
bring my King to safety my castle and
everything is good in the world he's up
to pawns and his Kings net right now
safe but here we had the idea that
material is nowhere near as important as
King safety so Grieco doesn't care about
this rook on a1 it's a full rook but he
doesn't care about it instead he wants
to keep the attack yes back there so he
could play Bishop g5 actually that's an
interesting move the idea being that
this bishop is hitting the Queen and now
black has to defend from this in a
little bit of an awkward way because if
I played f6 which is probably the only
move by the way now this King cannot
castle because of this bishop but on the
other hand black is attacking this this
Bishop on g5 and this rook on a1 right
so you cannot defend both so still a
type of sacrifice now can I give check
only one with my rook or I'll ask this
another way is it a good idea to give a
check on you one with the rook okay why
not yes right the bishop is still
defending here so I can take it and
suddenly you lose an important in the
attacker so now we see what's called
relative value in pieces
so while much is a rook worth five are
all rooks worth five that's not
necessarily true
some rooks are worth more than others
for example the rook on a wall right now
is not necessarily going to be part of
the attack any time soon
it takes clearing the Queen and then
clearing the bishop to get into a good
position
however the rook on f1 is very close to
actually providing some threats right so
right now the rook on f1 is more
valuable than the rook on a1 a little
bit of difference yes you had a question
how ok Seok we need to check now we
always have to consider our opponents
ideas right now I block I'm threatening
the king so he has to block my check how
would he do this
yeah no remember you cannot castle out
of check right that's a rule in the game
when you're in check you cannot castle
yes that is the rule yes you could block
with the knight or you could block with
the Queen now the Queen provides a
threat because now I'm threatening to
exchange Queens in chess it is pretty
hard to attack without your Queen it's
possible it's been done there are
exceptions to every rule but for the
normal game you really need the Queen to
deliver that final blow on your opponent
so exchanging Queens is not a good idea
here for white you don't want to put the
Queen's touching each other because at
this moment they would simply exchange
and then you will be left without your
main attacker so he doesn't want to
check right away although it's a decent
idea I see where you were going with it
right but he's not going to play king of
fade right you always have to remember
that your opponent still going to try to
play as best as he can
so I'm queening to check he's not going
to move the king he's going to block
with the Queen and then your attack is a
little bit stopped all right so here
Greg yep
so Bishop to h3 has the idea that if you
take on a1 you probably want to play
something like we need to check or rook
e1 rook e1 check and then I have to
block here right you can take you can
take take take and take and now why this
up material if we count White has well
let's count the difference this bishop
for a bishop one two three four five one
two three four five six seven two rooks
green so black has in pawns two extra
pawns right and white has a queen and a
knight how much is a quitter net worth
and black has two rooks how much is that
worth plus the two extra pawns wait
somebody said 13 I rely on you guys
blindly I should not do that I forgot
about that
all right yes 9 plus 3 is 12 and the two
rooks combined are worth how much yes
plus the two pawns so how much material
is white up zero actually the he is
better in this position because the king
is very exposed
that's true but materially he didn't win
that much now Bishop a3 was actually a
good move to be fair bishop a that that
final position is not so happy for black
but if you play Bishop a3 there are
other resources you can play for example
d6 and block out your bishop that would
be a little bit more sedate so let's
continue with the weight Greco deep
things he played Queen b3
and Quimby 3 has a double attack double
attack is a very powerful thing in chess
because kind of like in tic-tac-toe if
you cannot defend against both threats
you lose and in this case what are the
two threats yes yeah so now we have this
battery on f7 and this Bishop on c3 is
in the air it's hanging
so black continues his greed he plays
Bishop takes a1 saying okay take my
phone I don't care it's not checkmate so
he does and King f8 so right now we have
a battle between ideas we have King
safety who has the King safety here
white right against material who has
material here black now when we have
this kind of battles time is of the
essence
white only has a few moves to really
attack properly and cause problems to
black if black is able to finish his
development the extra material will be
too much for white to handle yes so we
start thinking of ways of attacking now
Bishop III check has the problem that
although the bishop is checking white
black and protect from this and develop
at the same time and you don't want to
give your opponent the opportunity to
develop yes right d6 now I can try to
bring my bishop out and this Bishop has
been locked out of the game okay yes but
you are not playing for material right
remember what your concept is now you're
playing for the attack even though you
gained the bishop you're still down
material if we count right Black has one
two three four five six pawns against
White's five so it's up one point and
right now how many rooks does he have
two White has one now why does have an
extra piece now when one side has a
piece or a bit
which means the bishop for a knight and
the opponent has a rook what do we call
the difference in material anybody no
okay it's called an exchange a rook
against a bishop or a knight having the
rook is the advantage so when you have
say you're up the exchange it means that
you have a rook and your opponent has a
bishop or a knight so here we black has
the exchange advantage and he's up upon
a total of three points ahead of white
so even though you recovered your Bishop
you're still a lot behind so it doesn't
help you to go material hunting you need
to be hunting for the big guys all right
unless you get that queen or the king it
seems like you're not going to have
enough material to justify your attack
so you could continue the attack how yes
you could play rook e1 bringing more
pieces into attack perfectly good move
what else yes very good Bishop g5 so
remember that we're trying to develop
with Tempe so this means that the bishop
on g5 is currently posing a serious
threat what's the serious threat yeah
the night we'll take the Queen correct
so this this Bishop is defended by the
knight so it cannot be taken right
instead of that white black needs to
defend this Queen because I'm
threatening to take it right so how does
he do this yeah so he has to play the
move 97 there is no choice but this
didn't help his development the knight
was already out right and now we have a
pin on it on top of that so this was a
success for white so far let's continue
the attack mm-hmm
rook e1 is possible rook e1 is possible
putting more pressure on e7 and by this
point it's possible that white already
has a couple of ways of winning and rook
e1 is a good way you're threatening to
win still a lot of material but not
enough remember that you're a full rope
down okay
instead of that he continues bringing
pieces forward to the attack he brings
ninety five in the knight controls a
particularly important square f7 and it
allows the Queen a very nifty little
spot now where do you think the Queen
can go thanks to the knight move yeah
right
so now we start to see how white is
weaving a mating net he is trying to
wrap black skiing up in a position where
he cannot escape so yes
f7 would be delightful because that's
where I can deliver Chuck made now also
possible is to thread and Queen f3 and
try to check from this file I notice how
bad blacks pieces are defending the king
so 95 was played and black continued
with this rampage of greed Bishop takes
d4 also threatening the night right and
Bishop g6 was played now why do you
think white is offering the bishop oh
right this is called a clearance the
Queen wants to go to f7 and deliver
checkmate and thanks to the knight on e5
it doesn't matter that you take my
bishop this is still checkmate likewise
if you take my knight Queen f7 is still
checkmate so black has to defend from
the f7 checkmate in a different way if
you put the Queen there I'll capture it
and it's still checkmate on f7 right so
you didn't help your position you just
gave me a queen the only way to defend
this is by blocking out the Queen how
can you do that yeah the e5 d5 was play
and now white must continue the attack
mm-hmm Queen f3 very good now the Queen
is aligned perfectly and the black King
has really no way to escape but here his
opponent goes back to a typical idea
when your King is being attacked and you
have extra material it is very common to
return a little bit of it to make your
King a little more safe so at this point
the King cannot go to g8 because I
simply checkmate them with King Queen f7
so black stops
this for now and defense with Bishop f5
he can take and but if the knight takes
what do you think what's going to play
Queen takes a five check now if the King
moves I still check made you and if the
Queen interferes then I take the Queen
right with a decisive attack so instead
of that black played Bishop takes Knight
why not right yeah so why it must
continue the attack here I want to bring
my records white so the Queen must enter
the fray again I have to give a check
but where do I put this Bishop all right
go on
now what ye 6 are not g6
you don't know okay that's fine
so here it Greco is something called
calculation calculation is when you try
to see our head in the game and see what
your opponent is going to do this is
usually a little bit easier when your
opponent's choices are limited so he has
two good choices on where to check with
the bishop he wants to move the bishop
somewhere where it defends f7 for me to
check mate with the Queen and that
square right that's the whole goal of
the ID of the situation so I could play
Bishop g6 or I could play Bishop e6
so what Grieco did here is think ahead
if I play Bishop g6 check black is
obviously going to defend right
that's the only good move now I would
like to take the bishop who do I take
the bishop with my own bishop now if my
opponent is helpful he will take take
King g8 and checkmate right but usually
opponents are not so helpful he would
take my other bishop and then how do I
continue the attack
so now Black has gotten rid it rid of
the knight that was only five and the
bishop that was on g6 and nobody is
going to help the Queen once it gets to
f7 yes
it would be check but the problem is
that once I moved to g8 I'm running out
of pieces I don't even have a good check
anymore so this would be a case in which
material triumphs when he has exchanged
enough of your pieces that he is simply
up a look in this case and he will win
the game but Greco saw ahead and thought
hey I don't need to put my bishop in
danger I will simply play the Bishop to
e6 that way when he blocks and I take
the one on g6 is not hanging because
it's now on e6 right so came black take
on the bishop on f6 yeah he can might be
really bad he can take and then take but
then Kenny 8 and then Queen f7 checkmate
right so black played instead the only
move that doesn't loose immediately
which is King e8 and then black sim
white simply continued the attack and
it's always nice to continue the attack
if you can on top of that take some
material Bishop takes g7 so now what is
blacks what is White's threat yes Queen
f7 check right now how can you defend
from this we Nev 7 is checkmate right so
you need to make it not checkmate yeah
well rook f8 I simply take the rook
right so that didn't help black yes
no okay yeah sorry this night where it's
too far
g6 okay but it doesn't really help me
because I still go checkmate right so
yeah Nidal f5 that would be interesting
unfortunately I can just take it and you
didn't really help your position that
much but it does pretty much checkmate
for now yeah okay yes very good Queen d6
is probably the best move in the
position so how can wipe threaten
something here let's give a check yeah
let's go Queen f7 anyways King d8 now
that's white how back have any do you
have any checks now no right no so how
do you think budget continue here yeah
well now I can take the rook so what
happened at the end White's attack has
been so strong that black had to return
material little by little right first he
had to return a bishop then he had to
return another Bishop and now he has to
give away his rook on h8 and what
happened at the end is that despite all
the sacrifices that white made early on
he is the one that has more material now
he has one work against one rook let's
count these as equals and we have one
two three four pawns one two three four
five pawns and there's a bishop right on
top of that my king is safe and your
King is quite quite the contrary of save
your record a eight is not doing
anything and I'm threatening what
checkmate with
Queen f8 because because blacks position
was so bad he actually resigned in this
position because now he has nothing left
to play for his daughter material he's
going to get checkmated really soon his
King is unsafe and he no longer has a
good plan to play for because his old
plan of playing for the material in the
long game has evaporated there is no
longer any any hope for him he decided
to resign so in old chess it was very
common to see all these kind of crazy
romantic games does anybody know what
romantic means a romance game in chess
some chess right we're not talking about
couples or a Roman game of chess is one
that is usually short in which one side
sacrifices a lot of material kind of
like in this game to go after the king
very quickly with a very powerful attack
and this was the style of chess that was
predominant for almost two hundred two
hundred and fifty years where everybody
thought hey I should give up all of my
pieces and try to check me my opponent
and black usually usually black was very
nice and usually accepted all the
material however later on it became
clear that there were ways of preventing
this from early on actually this
variation is now kind of defunct which
means it doesn't exist really anymore
because people figured out that at this
point black has already taking a pawn I
don't need to take a second one I'm
already on material so after Bishop
takes Knight pawn takes that control of
the center is most important you play d5
hitting the bishop with the temple let's
say the bishop retreats and you finish
castling so what what can you say about
the king is it safe right is White's
king safe yeah they're both safe but
what's the difference in the position
blackouts an extra pond right if we
count them three here three here but
there's four here and three here so
black has the advantage so a little tip
for your games of chess when you are
offered material especially early in the
opening be very careful of what you're
accepting you can accept them to a point
but never compromise your King safety to
go grabbing neither poor nor pieces it's
been shown since the very beginning of
chess that that can lead to very
dangerous and very disastrous results